good morning um so today we continue the
Vikings and this morning we will look at
their world view their cultural
system and um as I mentioned last class
I do believe that the Ving culture is
truly one of one of the outstanding
cultures in western civilization the
problem though is we know actually very
little about the Ving culture and there
are certain reasons for that the first
reason is that they were purposefully an
oral tradition so um it is our prejudice
it is our
belief that um a literary culture is
superior to an or tradition it's harder
to read and write but what we forget is
that when we transition from our old
tradition to our literary culture we
lose a lot in the process
and there are many cultures that had the
capacity to read and write but they
chose not to because for them it was
much more important to preserve the old
tradition um than it was to adopt
literary culture and as I explain in
today's lecture there are many actually
good reasons why you would want to
preserve an or tradition okay that's the
first reason the the Vikings were
purposely an oral tradition culture the
second reason is that that eventually
the Vikings would convert to
Christianity and in this converstion
process which would take
Generations they had to
abandon a lot of their tradition and
Heritage including their
mythologies and their historical
memory
um the Vikings were perceived as
barbarians by the
Christians and because of the traumatic
Viking encounters with Europe there was
an intention or purpose in trying to
eradicate the Viking
memory um okay so um please keep in mind
that we don't know that much about the
Vikings what we do know about the
Vikings comes from two sources the first
is archaeology we basically duck up
their graves some of their graves not
all their graves and have and through
their graves were able to reconstruct
some of their
culture but um the main source of our
understanding is through Norse
mythology um unfortunately we only have
a fraction of their entire mythology
their mythology it's vast it's Grand
it's epic it's beautiful but we only
have a fraction of that that and
unfortunately over time Christians uh
Christian
intellectuals want
to
sanctify or purify the Norse mythology
because the Norse mythology is extremely
violent and sexual and so they basically
clean it up uh which means that a lot of
what we have has been interpreted
through Christian
lens uh so please be careful about that
okay so I will try my best to
reconstruct the Viking worldview But
please understand there are severe
constraints and limitations and the way
I will reconstruct the Viking worldview
is by comparing contrasting it with
other mythologies other civilizations
other
cultures and by um using literary
interpretation um and ultimately by
using my imagination okay so please take
what I what I say with a grain of salt
be skeptical be suspicious ask questions
challenge me where you feel you need to
okay all right so let's get started all
right um let's look at the Viking
tradition in contrast to the Greeks and
the Romans okay so the
Greeks how do they see the world
remember um their idea of the community
was the idea of the polus
the polus is uh gives us our word for
politics and the idea is that a
community is a group of men only men who
come together to debate and argue of the
future of the community and as such the
individual is someone who stands out
okay the word they use is yonia or
ar okay udonia means flourishing you can
only flourish if you're standing out
among a group of men a is proving Your
Excellence among a group of men and so
um I'll give you two examples of this G
Greek worldview so the first is Achilles
from The Iliad remember in The Iliad
Achilles tells everyone I am in Troy to
seek personal Glory I don't care about
the Greeks I don't care about Helen or
Troy I don't care about what others
think I just want to stand out I care
about my own personal glory and that's
why he's willing to let Hector and the
Trojans almost destroy the Greek
army okay so that's one example another
example is from Herodotus his book
histories and it has to do with the
Athenian uh leader
fasic okay so this is a year for
80 uh BCE and in the year 480 bc. the
Persians are invading the Greek mainland
Sparta Athens have United against um the
Persians the Persians burned down Athens
and the Athenian people are on their
ships and at this point the Spartans uh
who are who is who are in command of the
military and Athenians have a huge
argument the Athenians want to challenge
the Persians uh
uh on the sea and defeat
them um and defeat their Navy the
Spartans want to use their Navy to
protect their Homeland the pipines
against the Persian
Invasion and they cannot come to an
agreement so what theic does is he sends
a spy a servant to the king of the
Persians and tell him hey the entire
Greek
navy is stationed
in
salamis
okay and but they're about to run away
from you so here's a great chance to
send your entire Persian navy to crush
the Greek navy once and for all and
that's what the king does and at the
Battle of Salamis the
Athenians and the spans destroy the
Persian navy and turn the course of not
only the war but of Western history
because if the Persian had won that day
then we would be living in a Persian
influenced world as opposed to a Greek
influen World okay when you think about
it what ailles and F are
doing um is what we would call sedition
or treason or betrayal okay but that's
just the Greek
worldview the
Romans had EXT had a very different
perspective the community as
fundamentally about tradition
and as such the
individual had to be
Pious to the tradition had to be loyal
to the to the tradition they Ed the word
piety now in China we have a concept
called filial piety guys this is very
important completely opposite okay in
China filial piety means obedience to
your father what your father says is
right
okay that's what it means but in Rome
piety means loyalty to the to the
traditions of Rome so the classic
example is Julius Caesar Julius Caesar
want to be king he was about to break a
lot of Roman Traditions so his friends
including his biological son Marcus
Brutus killed
him it was more important for Marcus
Brutus to be loyal to the traditions of
Rome than to the Lo than to be loyal to
his father okay so that's the Roman
tradition then you have the Viking
tradition for the Vikings and this is
very interesting the community is a set
of
stories okay and stories are not the
same as tradition tradition is what
is passed it is what is written down
stories are memories that are living
that which a community tells about
itself and therefore there's a
flexibility to these stories they can be
reimagined over and over the basic
structure the outline is the same but
the community has to constantly relive
and reimagine these stories and
therefore the
individual is a person who acts out
out these stories okay acts out these
stories and he acts out these stories by
either through
ritual either through Adventure or
exploration okay
so this is hard idea understand okay how
is this different from the Roman
tradition but let me tell you a story to
illustrate this Viking culture okay so
30 years ago a long time ago
I was having lunch with a new friend and
he went to a very good school called
Georgetown it's based in Washington DC
and it's where Bill Clinton went okay
this is where the a lot of the
Washington uh foreign policy Elite uh go
to
school and he told he told me that at
Georgetown there's a tradition a
competition among
undergraduates and the competition is
who can go the
furthest to do the most useless
thing and a lot of undergraduates
participate in this competition so what
my friend and his friend did was one day
they got in a car they drove 12 hours to
Canada the Canadian border they crossed
the Canadian border then they got out of
the car and went into the forest to take
a piss then he got back in the car and
drove all the way back to Georgetown
they spent 24 hours driving so that they
could so that they could take a piss in
Canada okay now you think this sounds
really stupid but the most interesting
thing about the story is that it is
memorable right
memorable and what this means is that 50
years after they graduate from
Georgetown people will still remember
what they did not only that but they'll
tell their friends they'll tell their
colleagues they'll tell their children
so this memory will persist over
time no one can remember who got the
best grades at Georgetown that year no
one's going remember who had the most
money who made the most
money in his or her life okay but
everyone going remember these two guys
who got in their car in 24 hours just so
that they can take they can go to Canada
to take a piss all right so that is
Viking culture it's not about winning
Glory or protecting tradition it's about
doing what is shocking what is new what
will add to the imagination and the
memory of the
community okay does that make sense all
right so their main memory is of course
their mythology Norse mythology and
Norse mythology I would argue
is the greatest
mythology in human history we still
have it today okay you might have seen
these Marvel movies right Thor the th
series um there are a lot of TV shows
based on the Vikings so the Viking
culture the Norse mythology is still
celebrated today okay so let me explain
to you why I would argue that Norse
mythology is probably the greatest uh
cosmological system we have okay so
first
it's
Grand in this mythology there are nine
Realms okay 1 2 3 4 five 6 7 8 nine and
it's all connected by a world tree
called idell okay no one knows what this
world tree looks like but it's basically
the equivalent of God in this system
okay and in and in this uh in ell there
are three uh Gods who control the fith
and Destiny
of the world called the nons okay so
it's very Grand and epic also what's
important to understand is there's
something outside this universe okay
this is
it second is that it's
complete what what I mean by that is it
has a beginning and has an end okay the
beginning is there's a rift and from the
rift steps steps a frost giant named
imar
and then comes a cow a cosmic cow who
then licks the eyes and that releases
another God who will eventually give
birth to another God who will give birth
to the three major Gods including Odin
and these three major Gods will kill
imar and from im's carcass they will
build the universe okay that's the
beginning but there's also an n and the
N is what we call which what they call
Ragnarok
Ragnarok and Ragnarok Ragnarok is the
end of everything it is a final battle
between the gods we call the is here
okay so Odin is
the um all father the main God but in
all children call the Acer okay the Acer
will fight a final Cosmic battle between
them and their enemies and in this final
battle everything will die nothing will
be left
okay then that's
it now as I mentioned the Christian uh
tradition will take the story and adapt
it for its own ends so in the Christian
tradition RAR does happen but guess what
after the end of the
world two humans a man and a woman will
emerge from the destruction and
reconstitute the world okay that's the
Christian tradition in the nor in the
north tradition as
ants and you may think to yourself oh
well this sounds extremely pessimistic
that's only because we're looking at it
from our perspective from the
perspective of the Vikings the end of
the world means that you must cherish
every single day live with honor live
with Glory live with
courage cherish every
moment okay okay and that's the
idea the third thing about nor mythology
is that is
Unified so all the characters everything
that happens is contained within this
mythology and contributes to development
of this mythology so this mythology not
only includes Gods but also includes
humans okay
who are champions of the Gods so very
there's a very famous Love Story within
this mythology between um a human named
cigar and a valkyrie uh who is what who
is a Serv of the Gods named um
buildi um eventually what will happen is
that there'll be a very famous German
composer named Wagner who will take the
story of cigar bohimi and this entire
Norse mythology and construct something
called
the ring
cycle which is the most famous opera in
German history and this becomes one of
the foundations of modern German
culture this Norse mythology will also
become the inspiration for
tokens epic called Lord of the
Rings
okay so these are the two most obvious
examples of how norise myology um still
impacts our world today okay and as we
go along the semester I will show other
influences all right so what nor
mythology is trying to do is create
Community among the Vikings and instill
certain values okay the three major
values that these
stories manifest and express our courage
the courage to explore the courage to
seek what is new and
unknown to venture forth into the
unknown because Vikings are mainly
explorers and
adventurers raiding is only a small part
of their Community okay second is the
idea of
loyalty and this is a
very important concept when you go out
on New Adventures you're usually going
out with your brothers your friends okay
it's like a Band of Brothers so you have
to survive you have to be willing to die
for them you have to die for each other
if it requ if the survival of the group
requires you to make the sacrifice you
have to do so a loyalty Loyalty means
love for each other it does not mean
obedience remember the Viking world it
is very egalitarian there's very little
hierarchy okay there are high status
people but they're high status because
they Prov themselves worthier than the
others because they're braver because
they are stronger because they're more
clever okay the last Viking value is
resourcefulness so the idea here is when
you venture off into the unknown you
cannot know what to expect you can't
plan ahead you can't be strategic
so you can only be
resourceful meaning you must respond to
the danger as it arises you have be very
what we call quick
witted you have to have Street smarts
okay so these are the three main values
or ideas that norish mythology is trying
to express and instill in the people
okay so that's a general introduction to
Viking culture now what I will do is I
will provide evidence and examples for
this argument okay all right
but is this clear to you
guys okay all right so so so now let's
do the
PPT
um and
uh look at the evidence and the
examples okay all right the the Viking
worldview
all right first thing I need you guys to
understand is that every culture every
society fundamentally ask itself three
questions that this painting from Paul
Goan captures okay where do we come from
where what are we where are we going
every culture is trying to Grapple with
these three questions Paul go gain I'm
not sure if you know who he is he is a
very famous French artist he started off
actually as a financier a stock broker
and then he basically became disgusted
with the material lifestyle of mar
Society so he got on a boat and went to
Tahiti where he painted he inter he he
interacted with the natives and through
this interaction he began to Grapple
with what it means to be a human what is
the human project and what he believes
and what most actually anthropologists
believe is to be human is to ask these
three
questions where do we come from why are
we here where we going okay and that's
ultimately what Norse mythology is
trying to Grapple with as
well okay so again we know our evidence
or understanding of the Vikings comes
from archaeology so we are able to dig
up their graves and what we discover is
and it's very interesting is that each
grave is
unique okay and it seems that each grave
in its own way is telling telling a
story about who this person is it's like
this grave was not meant just to send
this individual into the afterworld but
also to remember him or her and his or
her achievements and life okay
so um let's look at some reconstruction
of these Graves okay and you can see
this woman is buried with
tools an arrow as well as a dead horse
so we're not able to reconstruct her
story but obviously those who knew
her uh knew exactly what the story
represented
okay this is another example where man
is buried with his ship the Vikings are
the only Society to bury people in ships
um another example and as you can see
they're all unique in fact what's really
interesting for us is to appreciate that
funerals were the most important aspect
of Viking Society it's what brought the
community together and it was what they
remember the most it is funerals are
what contributed to historical memory in
the liking world as you can see this
funeral is extremely elaborate involving
a lot of animal sacrifice these horses
are being gathered up to be sacrificed
there's also human sacrifice and these
funerals can last for a long time 10
days okay so again because the Vikings
never wrote anything down we actually
don't know that much about these
funerals in fact we only have one
historical record of a funeral okay and
this happened in the Viking Roose okay
so this is Eastern the Eastern World
near the vogga and it was written down
by a Muslim Diplomat and traveler by the
name of Ahmad ibin fadlin okay and he is
from the Abbasid
cipit and he is in the Viking World in
order to negotiate a treaty of trade
okay the bassets and the Vikings traded
a lot and as an honored guest the
Vikings invited him to a
funeral of a deceased Chieftain or King
all right now there are certain things
about this funeral that's important for
us the first thing is that it would last
10 days okay it's a very elaborate
Affair that requires a lot of CH
choreography and coordination the second
thing is
that a third of the men's wealth were
spent on the funeral expenses so
basically A Feast for everyone okay a
third was spent on his funeral clothes
that was Taylor Made for him so the so
this is like the best clothes and the
third was given to his wife what this
tells us is first of all this man even
though he was high status he didn't have
that much wealth right and second of all
uh the Vikings are very egalitarian
society the third thing that's important
for us they didn't care that much about
wealth period right they spent a third
on the funeral they just burn away the
money
okay so what's also important for us to
remember is there is a funeral director
there's a woman who uh ibben fadlin
calls the angel of death who was
coordinating and orchestrating this
funeral during the course of this
funeral there are things that happened
that actually disgust him okay so so
before we continue let please keep in
mind that ibben Fallon he's an observer
he doesn't speak the Lang language he
doesn't know culture so he doesn't exact
exactly know what's going on second of
all he's a Muslim so he has he has his
own cultural worldview that's that is in
conflict with a viking worldview the
third thing is he is writing this down
after the fact and if you do that what
often happens is that you will
misremember a lot of things so please
take his description with a grain of
salt with some skepticism but also so
please remember that we have no choice
in the matter because this is the only
written record of a Viking funeral from
this time okay so we have we have
absolutely no choice in the matter so
let's let's look at what he writes and
then try to reconstruct the Viking
culture and understanding okay so first
thing he says is they cut a dog into and
threw the halves into the boat and place
the man's weapons beside him okay so
again they are celebrating his life they
are memorizing his life they had two
horses run themselves sweaty cut them to
pieces and threw the meat into the ship
finally they killed two cows a hand and
a CL and did the same with them okay so
not only are they remember him but
they're giving him supplies to help to
sustain him as he Ventures and voyages
into the afterworld okay now this is
interesting they asked for a human
sacrifice and a slave girl volunteers
volunteers okay clearly she didn't
volunteer but she
volunteers and let's see what what
happens meanwhile the slave girl went
from one tent to the other and had
sexual intercourse with the master of
each every man told her tell your master
that I have done this purely out of love
for you okay it's not this this is
incorrect it should be for him all right
so this is really confusing for us it's
a funeral and they're
having sex with the woman who who is
about to sacrifice
so we don't have we absolutely no idea
what's going on but I'm going to make a
guess I'm going to use my imagination
okay first it's important for us to
understand who the slave girl is she's
not a normal person I believe I would
argue that she must be the lover of the
deceased Chieftain why okay here's the
logic um Remember The Iliad okay in The
Iliad the ENT enire Story begins with a
problem the problem is that egam Menon
the leader of the Greeks he has
kidnapped a girl who happens to be the
daughter of a high priest to AP poloo
and the king and the priest comes to him
and says I I will give you all the gold
in the world but please give me back my
daughter and all the Greeks are said oh
you should do that egam Manan please
give back the daughter okay that's
that's just the custom of War a father
can Ransom the daughter you have to
return her but egim Manan says this I'm
not going to return her because I love
her I love her more than my
wife and as a result the high priest
prayed to Apollo who unleashes a deadly
plague among the Greeks the Greeks are
dying so finally Achilles steps up and
says to a Manon you have to return the
girl all right now EG Manon has lost
face so he says to Achilles fine I will
return the girl that I love more than
anything else in the world but you must
give me your girl your slave girl and
achilles gets so angry about this that
he refuses to fight for the Greeks which
leads to the disaster of the chosen War
okay so what is this telling us this is
telling us that in this world where
these men are far from
home and they kidnap these slave girls
they fall in love with them and in the
process of falling love with them these
Great Men conf First Status and power
onto these slave girls okay does that
make sense all right I I know this is
hard to understand but the slave girl is
not a
normal girl she is the lover the
mistress essentially the wife of the
chiefton who's
died okay so another question then is
why has she volunteered to kill herself
okay well if we continue the logic then
I would argue that it's because without
the man she has no status and Power in
the community she'll go back to being a
slave and she might be ostracized so by
volunteering and sacrificing
herself she will win status and power
and honor for her children and for her
relatives in the community she will make
her family part of that community
okay that's why she does this now then
the question then is okay I don't get it
now because if in fact the slave girl is
the chieftain's favorite
mistress and if this slave girl does in
fact
love um this man why is she having sex
with everyone okay and the answer
is in this world
gifts are very important basically if
you go to war and you win things you
have to share with everyone okay so what
this deceased man is saying now that I'm
dead I give you one final gift and it's
most the greatest treasure that I can
possibly give you which is the woman I
love okay and that's why each man is
forced to have sex with her and they
tell this girl when you go to your
master tell him I only do this out of my
love for him not for you I don't have
sex with you I do not want to have sex
of you but I will in order to celebrate
him to honor him to love
him
yes so Jun that's a great question in
their imagination are they having sex
with the Dead Master and
um yes you can make that argument okay
because remember in this world
homosexuality is not it just doesn't
exist it's very it's okay for men to
have sex with each other it's okay for
uh men to have sex with together with
one woman okay and that's how they
create intimacy and bonding because
remember when you're out in war you have
to be able to make the ultimate
sacrifice so you have to bond with your
fellow soldiers and the best way to bond
is through sex okay sex with each other
but also sex with other woman okay so so
yeah so you can make that argument okay
I again I don't know it goes on their
heads but if you extend the logic yes
then they think they're having sex with
a master through the
girl all right and that's why they say
I'm only doing this out of my love for
for him not for you but for
him
okay um so let's continue okay in the
afternoon they moved the slave girl to
something that looked like a door frame
where she was lifted on the palms of the
man three times so the doorf frame
represents access to the afterworld okay
so she's being sacrificed now the first
time she saw her father and mother that
second time she saw all her deceased
relatives and the third time she saw her
master in Paradise
okay so what this is is she the slave
girl who is not who is not part of the
community what she's really doing is
implanting her personal memory
into the community as a whole she's
making her family part of the community
now right she's talking about her past
and everyone again this is a community
event everyone's observing every can
hear her all right so they know that
after she dies they must honor her
memory by honoring her relatives and
family
okay there there it was green and
beautiful and together with him she saw
men and young people she saw her master
beckon to for her then she was brought
of chicken which she which she decad and
which was then thrown on the boat okay
again this some some some strange ritual
that I have say no idea uh what it means
but it must mean something okay often
what they do is they reenact mythologies
okay so there must have been a famous
story where a woman decapsulates a
chicken for some reason okay and she's
doing that they are reliving mythologies
all right let's continue there after the
slave girl was taking away to the ship
she removed her bracelets and gave them
to the old woman okay she she she took
what was most valuable to her and gave
her to the old woman who is the Angel of
Death the funeral director so what she's
doing is giving thanks to the old woman
right she's paying up she's giving her a
gift she's bribing her for the honor of
being sacrificed there after after she
removed her anklets and gave them to the
old men's two daughters then they took
her abroad the ship but they did not
allow her to enter the tent where the
dead Chieftain lay okay she's about to
she's about to be sacrificed the girl
received several vessels of intoxicating
drinks and she sang um these
intoxicating drinks are often uh
psychedelics okay all right so so the
psychedelics is are meant to enhance her
visuals okay now she's singing
before the old woman urged her to enter
the tent I saw that the girl did not
know what she was doing notes ibben
Fallon okay so iben Fallon is completely
confused by this but what we need to
understand is this is highly
choreographed right every person knows
what to do in this process it's a ritual
meaning that there's a script in place
and meaning that the chieftain and the
slave girl and the old woman all discuss
this beforehand okay
that's the only way this makes sense
then the girl was pulled into the tent
by the old woman and the men started to
beat on their Shields with sticks so her
screams could not be heard okay so the t
is being surrounded by warriors with
shields
okay six men enter the tent to have
intercourse with the girl after which
they laid her onto her master's bed
beside him all right so six men
basically rape her together and what
this is doing is reenacting the memory
of being with their Chief right going
out in raids sacking a city and then
raping the woman together guys I know
this is terrible I know this is terrible
but again we have to try to understand
their worldview and their
practice the two two men grabbed her
hands and two men her wrists the angel
of death looped a rope around her neck
and while two men pulled the Rope the
old woman stabbed the girl between her
ribs with a knife okay she's being
sacrificed by the angel of death and
that's how she
dies all
right thereafter the closest male
relative of the Dead Chieftain walked be
backwards naked covering his anus with
one hand and a piece of buring wood with
the other again this must come from a
certain mythology okay that that's the
only way we can explain this practice
why is he why is he going around
naked he ship the ship of flame after
which other people added wood to the
fire okay and that's how he
dies right again this sounds gruesome
what they're doing is they are
celebrating the man and implanting his
memory into the community because
everyone participates in this funeral
the man his memory is now part of the
community's collective
Consciousness okay he has become a story
within the community and therefore will
be remembered forever for his
achievements okay does that make sense
guys all right so this is again a
depiction of the
funeral and again the Greeks and the
Romans had
equivalents so that and we'll discuss
these equivalents so you better
understand what's going
on for the Romans that's something
called the Triumph the Triumph was the
highlight
of Roman uh life it was basically a
general who won great conquest and so he
came back in a milit military parade the
parade would offer a lot of things it
would offer some pictures of the
conquered territory it would it would
parade uh Treasures like Elephants or
gold captured from the conquered people
it will also parade
slaves um and captured people like
usually King
and it would feature the soldiers as
well as the triumphant General okay
what's important for us to remember is
at the end of this parade they go to the
Temple of Jupiter their God and they
will
sacrifice these slaves and these
captured Kings to the god to the god
Jupiter okay so it's very similar to the
funeral
guys um the Greeks on the other hand had
theater to build the community's
collective Consciousness right the
community all participated in the
theater so there were no professional
actors it was it was community members
that participated in the theater
and the um the community The Spectators
would judge which theater was the best
it was a highlight of the community to
pick the best playr for that year it was
the greatest honor it's like winning the
Nobel Prize um basically
okay
um the
theater was it's very different they
didn't practice any human sacrifice they
didn't parade slaves around what they
did was often was write about war from
the perspective of the
enemy okay so Ides wrote something
called uh children woman where he wrote
about uh the the the the children woman
who are r and captured and kidnapped by
the Greeks and isal wrote about the
Persian uh
laws okay and that's why the Greek
civilization is considered the most
imaginative in human history because
because it practices empathy it changes
perspectives it's willing to celebrate
everyone okay so that's that's the Greek
World
okay all right let's talk about a little
little about Norse mythology remember
what I said was that Norse mythology its
purpose is to express and promote three
values courage loyalty and
resourcefulness right so the example of
Courage is Odin at the beginning of the
world Odin who's a god of knowledge he
wants to seek all knowledge so he flies
around ell the world tree and he goes
into different Realms and he meets a god
what something call the wealth Cosmic
knowledge if you drink from the soup you
gain Cosmic knowledge
so Odin wanted to drink it but he had to
make an offering so he he offered what
was most valuable to him which was was
his eye guys okay his eye so he plugged
out his eye gave it to the God and drank
from The Well of cosmic knowledge but
once he drank from from the well and
learned Cosmic knowledge he became more
curious about the universe and so he
started to venture into more unknowns
eventually he went into through the the
realm of death and no matter how hard he
try he could not penetrate this world
there were too many winds there are too
many barriers
so he killed himself right because
that's what you do if you want to enter
death world you have to kill yourself so
he killed himself and he was dead for a
long time but in his death he was able
to see all the secrets of the universe
and then afterwards he resurrected
himself okay so Odin personifies the
idea of courage in the Viking world to
seek the unknown
relentlessly okay even if if it cost you
your life and your
eye
right okay the idea of loyalty all right
so um in the Norse World there'll be a
Ragnarok and there's a wolf Fenris who
will um foreshadow the Rival of Ragnarok
he's very dangerous but when he's born
he's just a little pup so the esar the
gods um basically decide to adopt him as
a pet okay they think he's harmless and
his master is tier who is the God of War
among the aser and but very quickly
fenus grows to be huge and now the gods
see him as a menace so they try to time
up but no matter how hard they try they
can't time him up and it becomes like a
game like and ferah think this is really
funny okay but the gods become really
worried so they go to the
dwarfs um and they ask the dwarfs to
create a magic rope which they do and
tier goes back to F says hey let's
continue this game of you us trying tie
of us trying to tie you up f is like
okay but how do how do I know that you
will release me if I can't get
out here put your hand in my mouth and
if you don't release me I'll take your
hand all right so the gods discussed
this and tear volunteers to do this
knowing that he's going to lose his hand
all right and that's what happens they
tie f fenus up and FIS gets wants to be
released the gods refus because he's a
menace and then fenus just cuts
off um B off the hand okay that's of
loyalty loyalty to your friend
right resourcefulness okay so the gods
are always at war with a frost Giants
one day a man named the Builder comes to
the comes to them and says I can build
you a wall to protect you from your
enemies for in 18 months okay this is
Asgard the home of the
Gods um and the Builder says I will do
this but I want three things I want the
sun I want the Moon I want the beautiful
goddess Freya in marriage and Odin the
Gods like no that's a stupid deal but
Loki who is the god of mischief and the
blood brother of Odin says to Odin take
the deal but make it six months give him
six months that way he'll get up he'll
finish about a third of the wall and we
can finish the rest and all thinks
that's a great idea okay and the Builder
agrees to this deal on one condition
that he's allowed to use his horse in
order to carry the bricks in the
concrete okay and the the gods agree
what they don't know is the horse is a
magic horse and the horse is able to
travel as fast as light itself and so
the Builder is able to really quickly
Build That Wall and he's about to finish
the wall Odin says
Loki you got us in you got us into this
mess get us out of this mess or I will
kill you so what does Loki do
Loki thinks and he and he he's a shape
shifter right and he SW and he's able to
shap shape shift into a m a beautiful
horse okay like this The Bu horse sees
the m and becomes really excited right
and he runs off and the Builder is not
able to finish the wall and Loki gives
birth to a horse a baby horse that then
becomes Odin's horse okay okay that's
the idea of
resourcefulness there are some really
funny stories with in noris mythology
okay one of the funniest is this Thor
has a magic H Hammer named moire he
loves it he loves it so much that he
sleeps with it he puts it under his
pillow one day he wakes up and finds it
missing so of course he thinks it must
be Loki because Loki is always playing
these tricks on the gods but Loki says I
didn't do it and I'll will find out for
you who did it so Loki explores and he
finds out that it was the frost shine
King who stole the hammer the FR King
will only return the hammer if the gods
give him
frea um as a wife Loki goes back and
Freya says screw off I'm not I'm not
going to do this so Loki says to Thor I
have a plan the plan is he's going to
dress th up as Freya he's going to put a
wedding dress and a
veil uh on Thor and Loki will disguise
himself as a as a bridesmaid
okay stupid plan but they do this they
go off and the frost shine King doesn't
really notice that that Freya is a huge
man they have this huge feast and
unfortunately Thor loves to eat and he
loves to drink so basically this huge
feast Thor is eating this oxen he's
drinking all this beer and he's burping
the process so Frost giant king is kind
of like confused but he's also really
excited at the wedding the frost giant
king presents the hammer moaner to Thor
and he lifts the veil to kiss Thor and
that's when he realized is that it's
actually a man then Thor gets his hammer
and beats a crap out of the king okay so
there are many stories like this which
are really funny and
imaginative um what do these
stories tell us about the understanding
of the
individual in the Viking world uh this
is Neil price and to prepare for this
lecture I did a lot of research
including listen to his YouTube lecture
which has over about a million views on
YouTube but he's a viking expert he's an
AR he's an archaeologist I highly
recommend that you um listen to his
YouTube videos if you're much if you're
interested in this material okay but
this is what he has to say about the
Viking
worldview the Viking the individual is
shaped by four
forces okay first is the hammer the
hammer is basically the shell or the
shape of the person okay the out the
outer uh being so it may not be the body
actually but it's the shell okay second
is the idea of the humming J the humming
J think of it as a pet who follows you
around and it personifies
luck okay and because it's a pet you can
you can either nurture the pet or not
nurture it okay you nurture it by
showing courage right so in battle if
you run off uh if you enter the Battle
of Courage the pet will be with you but
if you run away and you hide yourself
the pet might run away and in the liking
world all that matters is habing J okay
you win if you get lucky not not because
you're stronger the third idea is
Huger and hugar is your essence your
soul okay who you are really
the last idea is fij okay and fija is
what you inherit from your family it is
the guarding Spirit of your family so
think of it as the collection of your
ancestors who whisper you advice in your
dreams today we would call this concept
intuition right intuition that's what it
that's what it represents so as you can
see uh Neil price and other experts are
showing us that we think of the Vikings
as barbarians but in fact they have very
complicated and Nuance understanding of
themselves and the
world all
right okay so another question then is
how are the Vikings able to do this my
argument to you is it's
because of the oral tradition we are
simply not as creative as people people
who tell stories every day and who make
Stories the heart and center of the
community okay so um this is an over
generalization an oversimplification but
I want us to understand this graft
before people lived in the old tradition
what this meant is they told stories
when you tell stories you need at least
two people you need the speaker and you
need the
listener you can't do otherwise okay you
can't tell a story to yourself so you
need at least two people but often it
was a whole community that participated
in the stories and what this meant is
that the stories were living things they
were things that you played with that
were flexible they were a clay you can
change the stories over and over each
person who told the story would tell it
different so there are like millions of
different versions of these North
stories that I just told you okay
because each person can interpret that
story differently so these are living
memories and that and that means that
each story is unique now there's a
concept in cultural Theory called the
aura okay the essence the soul and each
story has its own soul if you think
about
it
right let's contrast this with literary
culture in literary culture reading and
writing you have to do it by yourself
you cannot not right with a
friend it would be terrible if you did
that
right but the benefit is that whatever
you write leaves you and become becomes
part of the page it's permanent
now and as a result your words can
escape time and space it becomes
Timeless we have Homer because Homer's
words were written down even though
Homer was probably illiterate okay today
we live in the visual culture so think
of videos think of photographs right
first thing to understand is that it's
passive both in literary and oral
culture you have to participate you have
to use your imagination to make the
thing alive but with a photograph it's
all provided to you okay it's a very
passive
experience um it's self-enclosed meaning
you there it's impossible for you to add
anything to it okay but you get more
information that way so there are
benefits to visual uh culture so for
example a map right if you look at a map
it tells you a lot more information than
if someone try to explain it to you with
words and the last advantage of a visual
culture is it is
universal so if an alien species came
down to our planet and looked at our
pictures they wouldn't know what's going
on okay whereas if they heard a story or
read a a book they would have abely no
idea what's going on right so this is
the old tradition in contrast with
literary culture and visual
culture the old tradition is extremely
complex we tend to think that it's just
about telling a story okay but if you
think about it there are so many
variables and nuance and factors in the
telling of a story that's why each
version is unique onto it
itself okay so I could teach the same
material but if we change the classroom
if we change the
students if we change the
lighting the experience of being in this
classroom would
change the north the Vikings the way
they told stories is they would tell it
in a big hall because remember it's
usually cold up north it's snowing
outside they would tell it in a big Hall
and it's dark so they have a big fire
inside inside the hall and the
Storyteller The Bard would recite the
story or tell the
story beside the fire as everyone um
listens some important things to know
about this first is the Halls were huge
they were as huge as a Greek Ampitheater
so you can see about a thousand 2,000
people within the hall okay second is
the idea of darkness when it's dark and
you can't see see your ears become much
more perceptive so the words have become
alive they're more color they're more
detail they much more imagery
okay and third is these War these wall
these words are bouncing off the walls
and they're creating Echo and resonance
and so these words almost like bonds
that unite everyone in the telling of
the
story okay and if you think about it
this experience is very similar to the
Ice Age remember last semester at the
very beginning we did the Ice Age cave
paintings and what we need to understand
is people came together in these caves
not
to paint in the caves but to tell
stories about where they came from who
they are and where they're
going all right
and all of our ancestors every one of
them for thousands of years participate
in this process of converging in these
ice caves and hearing stories be being
told to them in these dark wet caves so
this takes us back to the time of the
Ice Age It's activating a Nostalgia
within us and that's why the old
tradition is so powerful okay
all right so these stories have to be
told in a certain way to excite the
audience okay so think of this class in
this class we have no tests I don't even
take attendance so when I present
material in this class it has to be
interesting for you right why is it
interesting but it has it's shocking it
has emotions it has structure when I
come to class I actually do not script
out my class what I do is I think of the
narrative structure the story I want to
tell and then in class depending on your
reactions depending on the question you
ask I will change some of the details in
the story to make it much more
interesting for you in the old tradition
it's a cocreation collaborative process
and that's what what makes it so
powerful as as an experiment what you
can do is this think about think about
this
in class there might be some material
you found really interesting right so
then you go on YouTube I post these
lectures on YouTube to try
to remember the experience and what
you'll find is you cannot okay because
we've switched from or culture to visual
culture the same is true if it's your
birthday okay it's your 18th birthday
you got with your
friends and you have a wonderful time
and you're like I want to take a picture
to remember this experience but what you
will find when you you do that is the
picture doesn't really capture the
experience for you you cannot the
picture cannot bring back the feeling
for you okay and that's why the Vikings
were so insistent on maintaining their
old
tradition and not trans transitioning
into the literary culture because their
old tradition is what gave the community
purpose and meaning if you gave that up
then your community would lose
cohesiveness right
does does does it make sense to you guys
all
right so what's the old tradition again
we've lost it um we we've mainly lost it
but remember what it is okay let's take
two things that you know very well and
merge them together and then you can
experience what the or tradition is it's
basically the immersion of a movie think
of going to a good movie and and
remember the power the immers of power
of being that movie you are in that
movie okay you combine it with the
intimacy of a conversation you just
think of like having this like four or
five hour conversation with your best
friend and talking about life and love
in general okay it the old tradition
combines these two things and that's why
it's so powerful that's why it cannot be
remembered okay the Viking or tradition
was extremely powerful but it was so
powerful that it cannot be remembered it
cannot be written down
but as I will show you in future classes
this or tradition will go on to
influence major European civilization
specifically the Germans and the British
but also the Russians as
well all
right so again for most of human history
we as humans have shared our time
together telling
stories why do we lose the old tradition
okay remember this why did we lose your
or tradition well we transition to a
literary culture that emphasize reading
and writing so in
school um we have you read books but we
don't have you tell stories we don't
tell stories to
you we went from paganism to
Christianity okay the problem with
Christianity is it is
extremely uh simonia it focus on what is
good and evil whereas Pagan culture it's
like whether it's interesting or not
interesting whether it's memorable or
not memorable okay live a memorable
interesting adventurous life and the
Christians are like no that's not good
because if you do that you're going to
create a lot of evil so live a good life
avoid committing
evil last thing is the is we went from a
guaran world where everyone can
contribute to the story to a hiero world
where the top the elite insist on
indoctrinating us and controlling how we
think
right okay does that make sense to you
guys any questions so far so this is why
we left the or tradition and adopted
literary and visual
culture okay so to conclude the
class um I know there's a lot to take in
and it's a lot of information I
apologize okay but let me conclude with
a
story um
so I have two young boys and I sleep
with them okay and what I do is I tell
them stories I don't have them I don't
have them do math I don't have them read
books but I tell them stories where I
make them the characters the heroes of
the story so I'll tell you one story
that I told my youngest son Mau
okay the story goes like this it is Mau
fourth birthday and I tell Ma on your
fourth birthday something magical
happens you can pray to God and whatever
you wish for God will grant you your
wish so M was really excited and he
thinks a long time about what he wants
on his fourth birthday he prays to God
and says I wish for a room full of
strawberries every single day he says
that and God immediately responds
immediately in his room it's full
strawberries and malal he's he loves
strawberries he eats it right
away the next
day the room is also full of
strawberries and he eats it again the
third day again but by the fourth day
he's kind of sick of strawberries So
eventually strawberries overflow and
fill the
house and then they fill the
street at this time the neighbors are
really worried and we have to explain to
our neighbors oh it's because M wish for
strawberries and that's why we have so
many strawberries but hey let's share
strawberries together okay and the
neighbors are at first happy but then
eventually they get sick of strawberries
too and then the strawberries fill the
entire Street then the city of Beijing
is filled with the strawberries now it's
a national emergency okay the military
Comm signed C and we ever trying to
resolve this issue then the whole
country of China is filled with
strawberries then the whole Contin of
Asia is filled with strawberries
eventually everyone has to get on a
spaceship and get out of get get out
into space and go to the moon to
recolonize the moon but strawberries
keep on overflowing until they reach the
moon at this point the entire world pray
says to M listen you are fifth birthday
is
tomorrow please pray to God and tell him
no more
strawberries mama if you do this for us
we will make you president and king of
the world we will give you all the
chocolate in the world we'll give you
all the gold in the world can you please
do this can you please tell God no more
strawberries if you do that we'll give
you all the chocolate in the world and M
says yes I will and then fifth birthday
Malu closes eyes prays to God and says
Dear God I wish for a room full of
chocolate every
day and that's how the story ends okay
now it's a very strange story but guess
what my son's remember this for a long
time but not only that it's going to
inspire him to think about the story and
tell his own
stories okay all he has to do is changed
the story a bit and now he has his own
story he can change the characters he
can change some of the details all right
that's a power of the old tradition but
if I if I would write down this story I
couldn't say it in this way I couldn't
do it okay let's see how I would change
the story if I want it down okay let's
same story but now I write it down
rather than say it to ma
himself for his fourth birthday M prayed
to God for a room full of strawberries
every every day immediately his room
filled with strawberries he ate them
happily the next morning his room filled
with strawberries he ate them the very
next morning his room filled with
strawberries he did not eat them okay so
I I have to make the story shorter more
compact so that's easier to
read the house filled with strawberries
then the street filled with them then
the city then the country on his fifth
birthday Mama prayed to God for no more
strawberries his wom became clean and M
understood The Power of Words do you
understand why am I doing this why has
literary culture change the story
because now I know that the words leave
me and they leave Mal they go out into
the wider world and therefore people
will judge my
words they will think like I'm a bad
father or whatever I'm conscious of that
okay so I change in a way that is not so
offensive so that people can better
appreciate this you understand you see
the difference between oral culture and
literary culture in oral culture you can
be intimate therefore you can play you
can experiment you can be curious you
can be adventurous that's what leads to
the
imagination but in a liberty culture
everyone is watching
you 100 years from now people are still
watching you therefore you have a sense
of Shame you're very conscious about
your effect on people all right so a
metaphor we can use is this transition
from oral tradition to literal culture
is really like the story of Adam and Eve
where because they ate the fruit from
the Tree of knowledge they develop a
sense of Shame they
understood that they are naked and
therefore they're being
watched okay and because of this they
are thrown out out of the Garden of
Eden so I want I want to leave you with
that metaphor okay ear tradition we we
leave it behind and we think that it's a
good thing but we tend to forget the
power uh and beauty of the old tradition
all right so I leave you with three
questions okay to help us better
understand and remember the lecture the
first question is what is the
imagination what's the memory well in
the old tradition we would think that
the imagination is just an extension of
the
memory by making our stories memorable
we excite the
imagination therefore we allow for the
process of
creation second question is could we
have Homer Dante and Sher without the
old tradition and the answer I think is
no okay I think we would not have the
greatest poetry in human history if it
were not for the old
tradition in fact if you think about for
the past 50 years what has Humanity even
though it's there's like 8 bilon of us
we have more
wealth um and Technology never before
what literary Masterpiece have we
created I know you guys read the do Club
in school and it sucks okay I'm telling
you right now it is terrible it's a
piece of
crap and I can't think of a littering
Masterpiece of the past 50 to 60 years
okay there are some very entertaining
books all right but not of the stat and
power of Homer Dante and Shakespeare and
the last question I I have
is does
civilization make us less
creative
okay does being civilization make us
more
ashamed of
exploring of being curious or
playing or we less creative because of
civilization
all right okay so that's it guys any
questions okay so
um next week we start the we will do the
abysed califit okay all right so I will
see you
guys um next Tuesday